I'm getting slow in my old age shoppers
you knew got to hold daeyoung not for
lack of trying the greatest gladiator
match in the history of the world Son of
Krypton versus bat of Gotham
well here I am
you
hey youtubers is Charlie a new Batman V
Superman they also explained a little
bit about what's going on with flash in
the movie - and it sounds a lot like
what's been going on in the flash TV
show so I'm actually pretty excited so
in previous trailers we've seen this
Darkseid Omega symbol burned into this
post-apocalyptic wasteland is basically
like the big part of the ocean that runs
between Gotham and metropolis that
separates and they're separated by a big
body of water it's been burned up in
whatever giant nuclear alien attack has
happened I mean it looks like the forces
of apocalypse because we have parademons
but a lot of you actually did guess
correctly it has something to do with
seeing a vision of the future it's like
a dream that they have but it's given to
them by none other than Barry Allen as
the flash who has traveled back in time
with a very big warning of dangers that
are coming so imagine on season one of
the flash TV show when we saw that
future newspaper flash vanishes in
crisis imagine if this is that crisis
not obviously the movie and TV universes
are different but I love that we have a
Barry Allen who has already been the
flash for a long time coming back in
time to warn Batman and Superman which
makes me wonder how they're gonna play
with timelines because normally a hero
wouldn't travel back in time to try and
change the past normally the way the DC
Universe unfolds through time is that
big villains come along heroes come
together they defeat them they move
forward they evolve but what ends up
happening that's so bad in the future of
the movie universe that the flash is
like this can't be I have to go back and
fix things that makes it sound like
something happened that was not supposed
to happen in the past it sounds like in
this original timeline what what ends up
happening that's not supposed to happen
is that Batman and Superman do not come
together to form the Justice League with
Wonder Woman I don't know if that means
that somebody else came back in time to
mess things up
this is way too complicated and it's not
going to go down this way but doesn't it
make you wonder if the reverse-flash of
the movie universe the EU bar thawne of
the movie universe went back in time and
instead of trying to kill Barry Allen as
a child or trying to kill his mother
calls an audible and decides to prevent
Batman and Superman from coming together
no Justice League flash still becomes
the flash but they are not powerful
enough to take down Darkseid when Zack
Snyder said the flash appears in a
really trippy way in the movie really
fantastical way this is what he was
talking about so this might be the only
way Barry Allen appear
in this movie much bigger way in Justice
League in his own solo film
I think his solo film if he's already
been the flash for a long time and
Batman V Superman then his solo film
will probably address most of the things
that happen in his comic book the battle
with eobard thawne I'll be interested to
see if they try to change that narrative
because it's already been done so well
on the flash TV show that people are
like yeah we get it the reverse-flash
killed Barry's mother he tries to stop
him from changing the past there are
other reverse flashes by the time we get
to the flash solo film we'll have done
almost every single version of the
reverse flash but that is so far away
they don't have to worry about it for a
while the people that are riding the
flash are actually mostly known as
comedy writers so I'm actually really
excited I think it's gonna wind up being
one of the funniest DC movies which is
totally in keeping with the tone of
Barry Allen and a lot of you have asked
if they're gonna be doing the flash
movie does that mean that they'll stop
doing the flash TV show when that comes
no that is not the case they're not
gonna stop doing the flash TV show
typically like Stephen Amell for
instance on arrow said that he was
signed to seven seasons of the show that
was before they ever knew that arrow was
gonna be a successful show they didn't
know if it would go one episode or if it
would go a thousand episodes they signed
him to seven seasons so it's probably
the same deal for Grant Gustin probably
signed to seven seasons what will
probably happen is is when we get to the
flash movie is that they'll just try not
to overlap too much so the flash movie
wins out doing a lot of eobard thawne a
lot of classic Barry Allen stories we
just won't see a lot of those things
during that season of the flash now just
for reference the flash movie isn't
coming out till March 2018 that will be
during the second half of season four of
the flash TV show I know it sounds a
long ways off but it's actually not that
far and what I might do for my flash TV
show bonus video this week is talk about
big plot lines from the comics that they
can do on the TV show after already
doing hunter zolomon zoom so be sure to
subscribe to get that and I am doing a
new round of the DC giveaway this week
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's not for a flat ring anymore
they're completely sold out of flash
rings so it's gonna be a $20 Amazon gift
card you can use it to cut down the
price of the Star Wars blu-ray and I
know it's been reported that JK Simmons
has been cast as Commissioner Gordon in
the first Justice League film
immediately and all the DC films after
that and probably the Batman soma films
too
but that pretty much means that he's not
gonna be Jay jonah Jameson in the new
spider-man solo trilogy which I'm
totally fine with but I cannot wait for
the old-school Jay jonah Jameson memes
somebody tell me why Clark Kent is never
around at the same time as Superman it
is gonna be a lot of fun later tonight
I'll be working on a game of Thrones Q&A
and there's a new episode of Gotham I'm
gonna post the Gotham video on Facebook
it'll be a little bit shorter but I'll
be able to get it out faster while you
guys wait for me to post that video
tonight you can click here to learn
about the differences between zoom in
the comics and zoom on the TV show on
the flash TV show and you can click here
for all my other Batman V Superman
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight